he's Michael Wilbon co-host pardon the
interruption Mike good morning how are
you damn good how are you I'm doing okay
I wanted to ask you about what Steve
Kerr was talking about the whole Russell
Westbrook the next question now polled
George is involved in it and I it feels
like the NBA allowed
Gregg Popovich to get away with this
stuff and now the players are just
saying you know what I don't want to
answer questions certainly to this
reporter in Oklahoma Barry Trammell but
what would you do if you're Adam Silver
nothing I think the more attention
called to it
I was never you know me a long time
professional yeah I don't I don't chase
I don't chase the crowd I'm not chasing
a guy with the group of cameras I'm not
I mean talking to athletes is not that
important and I talk to athletes for a
living it's not that important and so
I'm saying that a great Popovich also
where people have to know and you know
this Gregg Popovich is in the top 1% of
guys who were not on camera or at a
lectern in a very public setting helps
reporters how many shots of you and I
had with pop on game days it might lack
me there are times when I've gone to his
office and I might just wanted to be
there five minutes or was there 45 so
there's another whole side of great
properties that people don't see on
television cuz he doesn't want to
whatever the game is yeah I don't care
I've had longer conversations that
matter more with Gregg Popovich in
almost any coach from basketball but
these players don't want to be told you
know Russell West we don't tell him I
mean don't tell him didn't then Russell
Westbrook plays which by the way this is
why I and I have so many people
associated with Oklahoma City that I
don't like and want to see advance in a
playoff any playoff you know we're going
back to Billy Donovan who I covered when
he was in college when I was covering
the Big East I mean starting with Billy
Donovan and Troy Weaver their assistant
GM was Washington guy and a great guy
somebody I've known for a while to Paul
George who now is being less brooked in
that that's not your G is not even who
he is a sweet guy Paul George and so
they're being direct so you know what so
what we should have learned from pro
football you know this Dan most of these
sound bites are garbage
most of the quotes I seen they're all
guys all people in our business
understand under the age of 50 is
analytics they want to put numbers
together they only know how to tell a
narrative half the time how to spin one
and so you get these quotes you get
these electorate pairs I don't need that
it's a waste of my time as a consumer of
the product so Russell Westbrook losses
and I started saying I got turned around
I started I want I want him out of the
playoffs
Russell Westbrook great player great
great great great great player I
certainly have my second team All NBA
ballot this year they'll have harden in
curry first team guards I have Westbrook
and I don't know different Damian
Lillard second team guards
I want Westbrook out there are people
there are plenty of people who don't say
next question Damian Lillard is one of
them there's no more enjoyable person to
talk to in the NBA than Damian Lillard
I want to see him advance and I want
Westbrook out that so you know what
pretty soon whispers gonna have nobody
to talk to you next week because his
butt will be out hopefully and that's
the way I look at that I'm not this hole
begging people you gotta have policies
you know you know I just I don't I'm not
chasing guys to talk to them it's not
that important it's Michael Wilbon ESPN
pardon the interruption by the way we're
in the same category for the Sports Emmy
outstanding studio show daily but you
one thing enough already can't you let
some other people have known on our show
my no not our show no no no no been
hiding some Emmys I'm not buying this
you got I had best studio host but I'm
talking about you know there's a show
yeah this our second nomination we lost
to MLB tonight last year you know what
really you know what I mean that's
something I watch I mean I you know a
really good I don't really sir would you
it's let's say you won because you know
Tony's not gonna travel to New York but
but you could be there and you could
go up and just say look we're not worthy
of this I think the Dan Patrick show
look I'll do the same this is what I
used to ask Charles to do and somehow
it changed the categories because
Charles and Kenny and Ernie and now Shaq
are not in our category anymore
but when they used to win this thing
every year we were in their category and
I was just at the Charlton or I'd be in
Charles's house anyway in Arizona right
Chuck you got like a letter that's
enough can you just go up and say you
know I'd like my friends to have one
yeah and actually when we finally won
one the first literally the first call I
got III was informed by Berkeley because
I wasn't in New York Charles called in
sick congratulations I go on what and
nothing okay I think I got it we finally
won maybe maybe we could go out after
the ceremony I got a whole group they
will kick it we'll celebrate like we
want am I wrong about you have to chase
people you got people who come on with
you every day for years you don't have
to chase the one or two people who say
next question but it really does Russell
whispered said anything that important
in the last four years that you need to
talk to him
no no exactly so why so just to chase
we're gonna treat this like the prom
queen I want you to go out with me and
so even if I don't like you that much I
you got to do it it needs to be a rule
well I think the NBA wants the fans to
tune in after the game and then you get
to you know if I was a player I would
take advantage of this and I said this a
long long time ago you know after they
said hey to Steve Nash and Allen Iverson
clean up your act and then they had you
know this dress code and I said you're
gonna get guys who are gonna go in with
like a Nike suit on like Nike he'll
start you know creating you know Armani
stuff and yeah guys will have their own
brands Dwyane Wade like then they
started doing it and that's what I would
do but I think I don't know if Russell
Westbrook cares about his brand it feels
like he does but then he gets there and
any just says next question and even
that's part of his that's part of his
appeal
miss appeals rebel okay you know I mean
it's fine like I don't hold again I
ain't gonna change the way I feel about
Russell Westbrook's play or when it
comes to me voting on these things I
mean I was certainly one another voting
them before him MVP once think I might
have done it twice I mean guys he's an
all-time great player does that mean I
need to hear him no it doesn't I know
and there's so many people in that
league Dan there's so many people in NBA
who are complete chatterboxes who are
engaged all the time I mean I wasn't I
was in Brooklyn I mentioned I was in
Brooklyn on the weekend I think that I
couldn't have had just two or three
encounters with Joe L&B you people can
dislike what he says or the way he goes
about I love it love him
there's so for every Westbrook and Paul
Georgie seems to drag along with him now
there's like a hundred and fifty guys no
I'm sorry 200 the guys who are perfectly
willing after a game to engage on
whatever level their personality takes
it and I'm I'm acting about that I just
too many guys read about Westbrook I
just had this conversation over the
weekend I think with mr. Tony actually
about Westbrook and how Paul George is
being Westbrook and this is not a good
move for Paul George if I say that is he
is engaging that was just great to talk
to great but you know next question
LeBron James is roll with who's gonna be
the next head coach doesn't why why are
they interviewing people it feels like
don't they just go to LeBron and say
LeBron who do you want
I think this is more a case of LeBron
specifically doesn't do that and he says
no no you guys hired me you want you go
to the fire but nobody believes that mic
well he makes them do that and then he
passes judgment on it right I mean
people talk about passive aggressive I
know I know someone enough to understand
what passive aggressive movies all the
time but I think in this case that's
what he does I you know they loved they
knew what they were getting they know
what they're getting with LeBron and the
one there's only one shortcoming in his
career to me
and is that about the number of rains
robe on the run James to me Islam is on
my personal not that matters anybody
else from Mount Rushmore of pro
basketball it's Russell Magic Jordan and
LeBron has I guess now for me replace
bird caws bird was that person for about
25 years and the one shortcoming is
LeBron hasn't been coached hard and but
the way I know that a couple of people
on that Mount Rushmore feel that way
he had been coach sorry he hasn't
accepted it he didn't have it in college
cuz he didn't go he might not have
wanted it
people say to me now so suppose Mike's
your chef ski I'm like no no no that
ship has sailed not them not that Mike
couldn't do it or wouldn't just just
that Mike is gonna coach LeBron hard at
this point no no I mean I don't know
that that you know he didn't have a
Chuck Daly he didn't have a Phil Jackson
he didn't have a Doug Collins he didn't
have I mean he he had paul silas for a
while how'd that go all sidles approach
you hard right i mean so so he didn't he
doesn't want it he doesn't he's won
without it he's not going to have it
I know players I know all time old guys
who think that LeBron truly would have
been the goat by miles if he had had
coaching that he took too hard coaching
everybody has it and he's won and it
worked he's gonna be a billionaire and
he can say I'm sorry why did I need that
again maybe he didn't make it the times
have changed how many primary guys get
that in this AAU world we live in but
that's that's what could be presented
because you can make the Kings fairly
easily that that's the one flaw yeah
yeah I I'm I had not heard that I'd not
thought of that with LeBron that if he
had somebody who would stand up to him
what that would have done mm-hmm and I
hadn't either again a couple of let's
just say top 10 players all-time have
said that to me and in one of them bring
a game and said listen you see why was
about LeBron playing in the post two
years ago in the finals are not
doing it and playing in the post for a
couple of reasons one you it's how you
get rest when you're playing 44 minutes
in a playoff game it's also how you open
up for the floor for teammates when
you're the best passer perhaps in the
league which LeBron is and it was and
they talked about how that would help
that team when it's lesser than say the
Warriors in terms of just physical
talent guys are injured whatever and I
heard that from a couple of old-timers
and I and I hadn't thought of it either
but that's why they're they think of it
because they see it they see the game in
ways that even people who observe it all
the time for a living don't so why we
tap into them and as soon as I heard it
then I was like yep yep that's right
that's right
hey one thing I wanted to bring up to
you and I I don't know if anybody has an
answer to it we recognize Babe Ruth and
his greatness in baseball but with Wilt
Chamberlain we go yeah but you know he
averaged 50 in a season and but who was
he playing against like why is it that
wilt we don't give wilt the benefit of
the doubt but we do Babe Ruth who was
playing before the sport was segregated
and what we'll did like that didn't
really happen and so that I don't know I
I just it's weird that we value
something in the 20s but something in
the 60s didn't really happen because we
don't include what we'll did well you
know that's a great topic I mean that's
that so I mean I work with somebody who
was just older than us enough and Tony
to be a wilt guy he's a real guy he says
exactly what would you say what you're
asking about now and I would say two
things one will didn't win enough he won
two he didn't win enough relative to a
guy he had to play against 16 times a
year who won whatever it was 11 11 of
course with rust and but I was I say I
think there's something else because I
grew up with a father who was a real guy
but you know I'd look at these things
now and it's not numbers um we'll played
on some great teams people say well it
will to play with guys as great as rust
no that's wrong
well played with that I mean you know
what a person I've got to know on the
phone recently he's one of my idols cuz
he did play for the Bulls for a while
but he played on will 1967 championship
team is Chet Walker Jeff Walker's a
hall-of-famer but all the people that
will played with he played with Jerry
West and Elgin Baylor for God's sake I
don't want to hear the Russell played
with better players just Tommy Heinsohn
he wasn't he wasn't as good as as Elgin
Baylor even though they played
essentially the same position did it
that that to me is why I can't put wilt
as much as I love everything about wilt
as a little kid I can't put him with
Russell and I can't put him with Kareem
because he played with great players
what happened you know they were up 3-1
in series on this Celtics they work to
owen series on the subdivision run more
and he was a great player so I think
that's okay to hold that accountable it
doesn't mean I don't celebrate will
because you're right when these when
these references come up at night on
whatever recap show you're watching and
and and either one of these guys is
always hard and most recently joining
something with the it's like so yes I
get that day and I do it's not
celebrated as much as not the NBA
doesn't have the film library that the
NFL does with NFL Films I mean I talked
to Steve Sabol about that at one point
they wanted to he wanted to do for the
NBA what he was wealthy AFL and the NFL
blocked it no I don't brought the stable
family again Steve Sabol I'm getting
that from but I think there's there's
all sorts of like how do we not have
film of something that happened in 1962
when a guy scored 100 points I've only
seen one picture in his will to hold it
[Music]
so Sonny Jurgensen
now he thought he was at that game
because they would have those NBA double
headers or NBA others staying in sub
headers and so the NFL had teams and in
the offseason those guys got paid to
play basketball so something with either
play for the Eagles or the risk ins in B
the basketball team I don't remember
which team it was but city comes out of
the shower he says at the end of the
first quarter world has like 29 and
sunny had arrived he was going to lose
and he says no no no I'm gonna stay and
watch this guy and so I guess I've been
around enough guys of that generation
who did appreciate wilt I don't I don't
have that that blind spot in my in my
rear view but I think there's some I
think not winning with the great players
he played with may have something to do
with that Mike I'll see you in New York
thanks for joining us as always treats
right yeah absolutely
all right that I'm rooting for you I'm
rooting for you thank you Mike
that's a Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption brought to you by Mercedes
AMG be prepared for whatever comes your
way the all-new GT 4-door coupe because
life is a race busy local dealership for
a test drive today for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app